Good morning.
I am filling in for Professor Hoffman who
is off addressing the French Parliament at
this moment, or maybe it was yesterday afternoon.
Tough choices of whether to stay here or go
there.
Well, that's right, Noah.
These days the issue of knowing where you
are, navigation is really taken for granted.
We have GPS in our cell phones.
GPS in handheld devices.
GPS tells the taxi driver whether or not he
should be turning up that one way street.
When we began with human space travel, particularly
as we entered the Apollo era, the question
of navigation, along with guidance and control,
was still a major issue.
In fact, it was rather uncertain whether or
not, in the Apollo mission, we were going
to be able to, with assurance, do all of the
navigation required for going to lunar trajectory
and then doing the precise navigation to land
on
the moon.
The
history of leading guidance navigation and
control has now, for a period of over half
a century, been located just adjacent to,
at one time part of MIT, the Instrumentation
Laboratory, now Draper Laboratory.
And the tradition carried on through Apollo
to the Space Shuttle Program.
And then, as I think as you are aware, beyond
that into NASA's current plans.
We're privileged today to have discuss with
us the guidance, navigation and control issues
on the Shuttle, Dr. Phil Hattis.
Dr. Hattis, a graduate of Northwestern and
Caltech with his PhD from the Aero-Astro Department
at MIT, has been at Draper since 1974.
He is a member of the Laboratory Technical
Staff, which is the highest technical position
available there.
He serves as the Technical Lead for the Crew
Exploration Vehicle Development Program in
GN&C at Draper Laboratory.
Phil has been very active in AIAA.
He is a fellow.
He has been head of the New England region.
Has received the Draper Lab Distinguished
Performance Awards and various NASA recognition
awards for his contributions to STS-1 and
STS-8 missions.
Then we will hear about Draper's contributions
and the overall issue of GN&C.
Thanks a lot, Larry.
I should just point out, when I came up here
as a graduate student to pursue my doctorate,
I was a Draper fellow.
I started working on the Shuttle as a Draper
fellow, so much of the work I will be talking
about here, I was probably only a year or
two older than any of you when I was doing
this.
And that's turned out to be fairly useful
to NASA because with the Shuttle still flying
from time to time issues come up and they
stick pick my brain about what we did in 1974,
'75 and '76, which wouldn't had been so easy
if I had been at my current age then.
But it is also a little bit alarming because
it means the people that are working on the
system now don't really understand why it
was designed the way it is.
Now, the other thing they could have asked
me for was the report on which this material
was based, which I wrote in 1983 to educate
the rest of the people at Draper who were
going to work on the program subsequently
about this system.
Now, the other thing I just want to say is
feel free to interrupt me at any point to
ask questions.
I am going to be covering a lot of ground,
and I may not get back to the area that you're
interested in asking me about if you wait.
So just raise your hand or speak up or whatever
you feel like.
And the other things I want to point out are
two things.
One, what you're going to be looking is largely
what was done for the first Shuttle flight
except where I mention specific upgrades.
Now, I am not going to be comprehensively
covering all the upgrades that have been done
to the Shuttle since.
What you will also note is this presentation
will be largely monochrome.
And why?
Because it is drawn from a presentation of
1983 when there was no such thing as a laptop
or PowerPoint and color was a real pain to
get.
You had to go to the artist and then get it
lithographically reproduced which was an incredibly
cost.
What color you see, I've added now and it's
limited, except for a couple of pictures at
the end.
I do have some before and after cockpit pictures
at the end.
You will periodically see a chart like this,
topics of discussion, we'll go from section
to section and we're going to delineate the
areas I'm going to cover.
There are going to be a whole bunch of sub-bullets
for each of these areas as I go through.
This will be not real deep, unless you ask
me the questions and I will go as deep as
you want with the questions but covering a
lot of ground.
Some of these pictures you may have seen in
one form or another, but I should just highlight
certain points.
The systems related to the flight control
were placed all over the Shuttle.
In the forward area, which was the only pressurized
portion of the Shuttle, below the livable
areas was the avionics bay.
And, in there where the computers, the inertial
measurement unit, and I want to say something
about that in a moment, what they refer to
as multiplexers-demultiplexers.
You've got a lot of analog systems or you
had to convert back and forth between digital
and analog.
And the electronic boxes that drove the commands
for the reaction control system thrusters.
And then you have hand controllers and displays
and indicators in the cockpit.
In the back you have pods which have many
of the reaction control system jets, the orbital
maneuvering system thrusters.
And I will be talking quite a bit more about
them later.
And there was also in the aft avionics bay
that had specific subsystems for which it
was deemed unacceptable to have them forward.
Some of them were local analog digital conversion
boxes, but also rate gyros which were used
during assent and entry where they wanted
them closer to the center of mass by being
in the back and in the front avoiding some
of the flexure issues associated with the
long distance to the front.
This particular configuration you're looking
at is before the external tank separated after
the solid rocket boosters had come off.
This configuration is where the story begins
because what I am going to be talking about
is the part that Draper did which is the exoatmospheric
flight control system.
And that begins at main engine shutdown and
ends when you hit 400,000 feet on the way
back.
There are different phases that we will be
talking about.
The first is what we refer to as insertion
which is from the time the main engines cut
off to the time you do initial orbit circularization.
And that includes a brief but design challenge
phase while you're attached to the external
tank.
It includes the separation maneuver from that.
And, in the original flight profile for the
Shuttle two burns of the orbital maneuvering
system, the original orbit insertion strategy
for the Shuttle put it in an orbit that typically
had an apogee of about 60 nautical miles,
a perigee of just a few nautical miles.
What you would do is the first burn would
raise that perigee up to the 100 plus nautical
mile target altitude and then the second burn
halfway around the earth would put you into
a circular orbit and then you would begin
your mission there.
Later in the program for overall efficiency,
in order to improve the payload margins, that
strategy changed.
And they tended to do more what they call
direct insertion which had a substantial higher
apogee.
The perigee wasn't much higher but you would
end up somewhere between those two.
And then you would do one OMS burn and you
would get a net gain of maybe one or two thousand
pounds which became very important.
During this insertion phase all the applicable
sensors were on.
Now, I said I was going to say something about
the IMU.
And most of you don't even think probably
these days about having rate gyro separate
from an inertial measurement unit.
You get these combined packages called inertial
navigation systems now.
They're actually navigators that have the
software.
They do all the processing for you.
They even have built in GPS receivers.
Of course, we didn't have GPS then.
The inertial measurement unit was a pretty
clunky gimbaled device at the time the Shuttle
first flew.
It subsequently got upgraded to ring laser
gyro systems.
But that inertial measurement unit was simply
outputting angles that were significant throughput
issues.
Because you had to do a lot of data crunching
to get rates from that.
Computers are really slow.
I will talk a little bit more about that in
a few minutes.
Having rate gyros separate was a way to get
data that these days would be all built into
one box.
General purpose computers, all of them were
on during ascent.
I will talk about the partisan of them, but
there were actually five of them.
And the Vernier reaction control system, which
is a small group of jets, and I will point
those out later, were not active.
The larger thrusters were.
And then, after the second OMS burn, you transition
to another flight phase.
And why all these flight phases, I will get
to in a couple minutes also.
Then orbit phase began after the second burn.
You quickly open the doors so that you could
dump waste heat.
The radiators are on the inside of the doors.
And, when the doors are closed, the heat just
radiates back into the vehicle.
All payload operations are during this phase.
And you did a lot of power down to save.
You're working off of fuel cells.
It limits your mission life both because of
the limits on the weight of the reactants
and on the places you can put any extra tanks.
So you turn off the rate gyros, you don't
need those anymore, and I will explain why.
Two of the five general purpose computers
were shut down.
This also being a late `70s computer design,
you're talking maybe on the order of a couple
hundred watts per computer which, by the way,
I will explain more about, but was a 104,000
word memory capacity.
That was actually an improvement from the
approach and landing test when it was 64,000
words.
And then you turned off two of the three redundant
inertial measurement units, except for critical
phases.
Also the safe power, the feeling was that
if you lost your navigation reference you
would have a relatively benign environment
to bring one of the others up.
And the Vernier thrusters were made available
because they were used for flying control.
Then you have the deorbit phase.
You close the doors again.
You do the deorbit burn.
You dump any residual propellant from the
forward tanks by simultaneously burning opposing
thrusters in order to get an acceptable center
of mass for entry.
Getting the acceptable location of the center
of mass for attitude and thermal control during
entry is very critical.
You reactive all the sensors.
You go back to all the computers being up.
Then you turn the Vernier jets back off and
you fly the vehicle using this mode until
you're at 400,000 feet which is about where
you pick up 0.05 Gs.
And that is where the entry phase takes over.
And this is just a summary of the profile.
Now, this is where I wanted to take the opportunity
to talk a little bit about computers and profiles
and everything else.
When we started this program with a 64,000
word computer, I talk in terms of words instead
of bytes.
The architecture of this computer didn't have
bytes.
You had words and half words.
Each word was equivalent to about four bytes
in terms of number of characters you could
insert into it.
But you only could break it down into pieces
of two.
So we had 208,000 - well, a thousand times
24 pieces of memory that we could work with
on this computer.
For the approach and landing test, which was
very limited, you flew it off of a 747 for
a couple of minutes, 64,000 words worked just
fine.
And they were chugging along with the program
saying we're going to get all this orbital
mission stuff into that computer.
And, of course, we discovered probably a year
after we really began the job, we began the
job seriously in '75, and by '76 it was obvious
64,000 words wasn't going to work.
They upped it to 104,000 words.
It was probably obvious four months later
that 104,000 words wasn't going to work.
So the solution, in addition to descoping
as much as possible, what you had to have
was to separate the computer loads that you
had for up and down which you did when you
were doing your orbital mission.
And then you had something called the mass
memory device which is basically a tape drive
which when you went from this phase to this
phase would reload some of the computers.
And then you went from this phase to this
phase we'd reload them again.
And I said there were five of these computers.
Four of them, of what I'll be talking about,
were the primary computer set.
Quad redundant so that they would vote all
data going in and out to decide whether or
not there was an inconsistency between one
computer and the other.
And it would automatically deselect the bad
computer, the implications of which I will
talk about probably about three-quarters of
the way through the presentation.
When you went up and down, all four computers
were operating the same software.
The fifth computer was called the backup flight
control system.
And the reason it was there, these four primary
computers, a chunk of that 104,000 words,
probably 30,000 to 40,000 words was used to
assure the computer set operated successfully
redundantly.
There was always a concern that there would
be a generic software error that would show
up at some bizarre time and that you could
pull down the whole computer set.
It was an independently coded similar architecture
from the standpoint of algorithm content,
but independently coded software called the
backup flight control system that on the hand
controller there was a button the crew could
hit, a panic button, if they needed to.
And the system would revert from the primary
system backup system.
It never happened in the history of the program,
it has never been used, but it is still there.
And so those five computers are all operating
on the way up and on the way down.
Now, when you go to the onboard phase, and
only three computers are up, you freeze dry,
as they say, to the computers.
One computer remains the backup flight computer
turned off ready to turn on from emergency
entry to backup.
The other one is a primary software load ready
to start.
The remaining three computers, two of them
were redundant set for the on-orbit functions.
And one of them, again, because of memory
problems, everything payload related was in
a system management and monitoring other non-flight
control related functions with one of the
other computers.
They did this spread of functions across computers,
in addition to adding the tape drive in order
to accommodate the memory constraints because
the Shuttle Mission was so much more complex
than what the computers were originally designed
to accommodate.
So you say it never happened.
Have there been instances in which any of
the backup computers have been brought online?
There have been instances in which primary
computers have failed.
There has never been an instance in which
they've reverted to the backup system.
Now, when the primary systems fail, and I
will elaborate this in more detail, while
each computer computes the functionality for
everything, they only control more or less
a quarter of the subsystems.
And there is a distribution.
And some of the charts towards the end will
talk about how this was done.
And there are implications associated with
what you lose when the computer goes down.
But, if you have time in your noncritical
flight phase, you can restring those things
to the remaining healthy computers and recover
accessible systems even though that computer
has gone down.
Now, on STS-9, that was incidentally our MIT
department's first Shuttle flight.
And it had, Byron Lichtenberg, one of our
people.
And what turned out happened to be floating
solder balls and an early version of these
computers that caused intermittent shorts.
And one computer went down before entry.
They recovered the string.
Another computer went down during entry.
And, because they had reconfigured the string,
they had three of the four strings left but
only two computers.
And another one failed on touchdown.
And had that one failed before touchdown they
probably would have reverted to the backup
system.
That's the closest they ever came to a backup
Now, the question that comes to my mind there,
since the generic failure was not software
but floating solder balls, which all the computers
were susceptible to, what would have happened
if they had gone to the backup system?
Because it could have gone down, too, and
then they would have had nothing.
Because, once they've gone to the backup,
it is not easy to revert in critical flight
phase to the primary system.
Lichtenberg, as I mentioned, was a crew member
from our lab.
Later I asked him how did he feel when the
first computer went down and then the second
computer went down?
Byron has an aero-astro PhD and pretty savvy.
He said he was pretty worried until he looked
at the commander, who was John Young, and
John said well, we might as well go to sleep
because we're not going to reenter today.
And when John went to sleep he said he might
as well go to sleep, too, and it will be all
right.
And it was.
Yes?
[AUDIENCE QUESTION] The computer was the same.
The software was not.
The computers themselves are all interchangeable
AP101 computers.
Subsequently, they were changed to AP101S
computers, which is modified version that
was used on the B-1 Bomber.
And they went to 256,000 words of memory.
And that is the current state-of-the-art.
You have to understand several things.
One, it is very expensive to upgrade systems
that are already flying.
But, independent of that, you never fly in
space something that is close to the state-of-the-art
because you have to go through all the qualifications,
which takes a lot of time, and it has to be
radiation hardened when you're in space.
And when it's a human vehicle, it has also
got to go through human qualification.
The Space Station architecture is IBM 386
processor quality, so it is basically like
maybe about 1986, '87 early laptop generation
computers.
[AUDIENCE QUESTION] Oh, yes.
There were quite a few missions.
I don't think there have ever been any missions
where they lost two.
The IMU failures don't seem to have been anything
systemic but just sort of a random problem.
And I'm not sure since they have gone to the
ring laser gyro systems that they have had
any failures.
I think it was the mechanical ones from the
early days that they had some problems.
Now, major requirements for the systems.
We had two different autopilots for three
phase transmission which incorporated both
the insertion and the orbit features and on-orbit,
so we only had two different software loads
on that tape drive for the primary flight
control system.
The rules for Shuttle were that after any
subsystem failure you have the capability
to remain operational.
No critical functions were lost.
After two failures, safe operation, all critical
things necessary to terminate the mission
and bring them home would be possible.
But some of the mission objectives may not
be achievable.
The system was mainly aimed at controlling
rigid body characteristics and velocity changes
within specification.
Only when we started to look at docking with
the mirror in the Space Station did we start
worrying about flexible body effects.
And it was because of what they were attaching
to and not because of the Shuttle, all those
appendages and those things.
If Shuttle does control Space Station and
did control Mir when it was docked.
And so there have been some modes, which I
won't really be talking about today, but were
created to facilitate that control without
causing unacceptable loads on those flexible
appendages of the stations.
And 80 millisecond app cycle, two reasons
that happened.
We originally planned to do 40 milliseconds.
The approach and landing test program was.
First there is less process of burden if you
do it half as often.
And the other, when it came to the reaction
control system, as we discovered in about
early 1980, a little more than a year before
the first flight that there was a water hammer
effect in the propellant lines on the RCS
jets were the opening of the valves caused
an expansion wave which reflected as a compression
wave.
The closing of the valves caused a compression
The inner section compression waves, if the
valves were opened and closed too quickly,
could cause a catastrophically large compression
wave that could burst the line.
So they deemed it better rather than redesign
the entire feed system to limit us to never
firing faster than 80 millisecond cycles.
Now, that differed from Apollo.
Apollo had 100 millisecond cycle time, but
they had the ability to interrupt the cycle
to turn out enough jets if they wanted a short
firing.
We couldn't do that because of the water hammer
effect.
And also because the propellant feed system
involved a liquid in the tank with zero G
acquisition devices around the surface of
the tank directly exposed to the pressured
helium, which means some of the helium dissolved
into the fluid.
If the fluid was drawn too fast the helium
could bubble out causing a gap in those zero
G acquisition devices around the tank preventing
flow.
If you get unbalanced flow of hypergolic propulsion
systems you can also get an explosion.
So the solution to that was limiting how many
jets you could fire at one time off of one
tank.
Does everybody understand what the zero G
acquisition problem is?
It's a surface tension base.
You have various types of rings and shapes
on there that captured fluid by surface tension
to there, which would begin to draw the fluid.
And once you began to get some flow because
of firing things it would pull the blobs of
fluid into the tanks and into the feed lines
from the tanks.
As you recall, the origin of the problem is
that the fluid would not be at the bottom
of the tank so you risk drawing a bubble.
The surface tension holds enough there to
start the firing.
When you fire you get some force.
The force draws the blob to the same parts
of the tanks where you can acquire the fluid.
And, as long as you don't draw too fast, the
communication between that part of the tank
and the fluid remains.
This was a very complicated qualification
program.
A lot of C135 parabolic trajectory time got
used to test out various perturbating of the
inside of the tanks.
And I am not going to talk about that in detail
but I'm sure there are a lot of papers out
in the literature about how they qualified
these things.
And I don't think there were too many systems
before the Shuttle that actually did it this
way.
One used systems that tended to use membranes
where you had the pressure on one side and
the fluid on the other side, and the membrane
would just force the fluid to stay in contact.
But the problem is the membranes would degrade
over time on exposure to these hypergolic
propellants.
Hydrazine and nitrogen tetroxide are very
chemical reactive materials.
For instance, it was supposed to be used over
many years up to a hundred times.
The idea that you would have periodically
keep opening up these tanks to change a membrane
was not attractive when you consider the tanks
are deep inside of the structure.
So this may have been a unique issue because
of a reusable system, but it also may be relevant
to systems that even if they aren't reusable
have to have a very long life in space.
Modes and submodes I will quickly go through,
but you have rotation and translation modes.
These modes could be used simultaneously for
the RCS system and then separately for the
OMS system.
And you had special modes which to get extra
oomph out of the RCS jets, if you had an abort,
that would sometimes be done if the OMS engineers
weren't available.
The OMS engines, there were two of them which
were up on the back right and left pods from
that picture I showed a few minutes ago.
And you could use one or two depending on
what you were doing.
And in the RCS rotation modes, you had various
ways you could use it.
Proportional meant you moved the stick.
The response you get is in proportion to what
you do, how long the jets fire.
Discrete means you move the stick and you
get a specific amount of rate change.
Pulse means you just get a single little pulse
out.
And acceleration means as long as you're holding
the stick out it keeps firing them.
And those are all.
There were push button displays that the crew
could adjust.
There were some modes for each of those which
affected how many jets fired, whether or not
you wanted to force it to use something that
approximated couples or you were in propellant
conservation mode and you were willing to
get accept getting a rotation rate.
With coupled in the translation you would
care about that effect.
And in the translation there were various
submodes as well.
And, in particular, you would use more jets
when you were separating from the external
tank to get away as fast as possible.
Yes?
On the previous slide, are there different
modes for the RCS jets?
Was there one that they happened to use the
most or was like supposed to be the primary
usage or are they all part of the normal operating?
I think they would rarely use this or this.
I think these two were commonly used.
This is very fuel inefficient.
It would only be used as kind of an emergency
measure.
That's also very difficult from the point
of view of the pilot to have direct acceleration
control.
Right.
I mean this might be something you would call
upon if actually, for some reason, the vehicle
started to spin up unexpectedly and you would
have to neutralize that.
Does that adequately answer your question
for now?
There will be an opportunity to collect a
little more detail on that later.
But, again, you wanted to get off the tank
quickly so you would use all the jets you
had to get off of it.
You wouldn't do that later.
You would have more jets that you would use
for roll control while you're on the tank
because you had a much higher roll inertia.
You want to only spend a few seconds on the
tank after the main engines shut down.
You could often be left with residual rates
you've got to quickly kill.
There was an inhibit on the separation if
you had more than half a degree per second
on each of the axes.
There was actually a phenomenon on the first
Shuttle flight which almost got us in trouble.
One of the first things that happens after
the main engines shut down is you slew the
engines back to stow position where you want
the engines for entry.
The reason is the auxiliary power units are
needed to move the main engines.
You want to shut those down and save the hydrazine
for those until you get back to it just before
entry.
On the first Shuttle flight they kicked those
engines at about one hertz.
It turned out the first fundamental mode,
the rock mode of the orbiter on the external
tank had a subharmonic of about almost exactly
one-fourth of that slew rate on the main engines.
The slewing of the engines then causes the
rocky mode to be excited.
We were seeing oscillations very close to
the inhibit for the separation.
The crew was getting a little worried but
we just got it in bounds in the automatic
mode.
And if they hadn't separated in time it would
have gotten pretty complicated to do it manually.
We made quite a few changes after that.
There were a lot of things we learned on the
first flight, and I will point a few of them
out as we go along.
There was also a launch pad phenomenology.
It is not part of my talk.
Has this come up in the class about the shockwave
from the SRB ignition?
Yes.
OK.
They didn't have those waterbeds in there
on the first flight.
What was relevant here, one of the things
that you may or may not know is that the struts
that held the forward RCS tanks on the first
flight were buckled almost to failure.
That wasn't realized until they got home,
but had they failed they probably would have
burst and blown up the vehicle.
The on-orbit modes, we have both primary and
Vernier jets which were only used separately,
except under special circumstances which were
designed substantially after the first flight.
We have local, vertical and inertial frame
of reference control capability with respect
to the discrete rate mode.
And, otherwise, it is pretty similar to what
you saw in the previous picture.
And submodes, some features were added because
of rendezvous.
You could fire a lot of jets on the fort side.
If you wanted to do a rapid breaking, you
could inhibit all the jets to fire in that
direction.
If you wanted to limit the use of plumes,
it turns out that you didn't lose completely
your translation control authority.
Because the jets, in the front and back, that
were in the x-axis coupled about 20% of the
trust into the z-axis.
So if you fired them simultaneously in both
directions you could avoid pluming an object
in front of you and still get enough translation
to control that axis.
And, just to show how everything was hooked
up, the inertial measurement units and rate
gyros and hand controllers and panel controls
all went in through these multiplexer devices
feeding the signals then into the computer
and displays.
And then you had outputs going through these
similar types of electronic boxes specific
to the reaction control jets that generated
the commands that were needed by the solenoid
valves that actually opened and closed the
hypergolic feed lines.
Looking at the whole top level architecture
then of the GN&C system is all those boxes
feeding into what was inside of the computer.
Inside of the computer you have subsystem
operation software managing each of the subsystems
doing the redundancy management.
The specific guidance navigation control algorithms.
There was a moding and sequencing function
which was based on both manual and automatic
scripts.
Then the actual driving of the displays of
controls is interactive with the flight control
system both ways providing feedback to the
crew members and accepting their inputs.
And then what was left was the system management
function on this computer that didn't go into
the separate computer.
By the way, anything related to robotic arm
operations were operated through that separate
computer.
One of the issues that came along later in
the program is the flight control computer
never knew what was happening with the arm.
If you take a space telescope sized payload
and put it 40 feet out there, it drastically
changes the mass properties.
And one of the features you will see a little
later that we stuck in was the ability for
the crew, by pushbutton, to select different
tables about expected accelerations of the
jets because we didn't know when we needed
to respond to that.
There were also flexure issues with the arm
which came up as they went along, too, and
established constraints on how we operated.
But was there any thought given to having
an adaptive system which would identify the
current parameters?
That would have gone way beyond the capacity
of the computers that we had.
It would be relatively easy to do with the
programs we had but it would never fit in
a 104k memory computer.
But there has been lots of work that some
of my graduate students have done over the
years of how we should have done that.
Brent Appleby, who is now a division leader
at the Lab, actually did some work back in
the `80s, I think that may have been his master's
thesis, on some of those issues.
[AUDIENCE QUESTION] But, in reality, we're
approaching very large memories which would
allow you to do it.
Well, when we go into CEV, we're probably
going to assume that 100 megabytes is no big
deal.
[AUDIENCE QUESTION] unfortunately was cancelled,
but we were doing exactly that.
We knew exactly the position [NOISE OBSCURES]
all the movement when we were grappling.
And we were changing all the tables based
on the current angles [NOISE OBSCURES].
It is a real challenge to maintain stability
on a system where you have no insight into
that.
But you would never build a spacecraft that
way today so I'm not sure.
The challenges we have are very interesting
but probably no longer relevant.
The challenges that remain are the flexural
dynamic interaction problems.
I just wanted to indicate that within the
control laws you have a steering processor,
which I will talk a little bit about more,
an RCS jet processor, a state estimator and
an OMS processor.
The state estimator is unique to the on-orbit
flight.
And there is more that represents that in
a minute.
So I am going to now, having entered the overview,
go into each of the subsystems in more detail
by pulling up this picture to talk about it
a little more, these subsystems in the context.
The forward RCS system had 14 primary 870
pound jets and two Vernier 24 pound jets.
There were 24 and 4 respectively.
Those systems in back evenly divided left
and right.
Each of the pods in the back had one OMS engine.
The forward RCS system had its own self-contained
hypergolic tanks.
The aft system had RCS tanks and OMS tanks
which could be interconnected from within
the pod or could be cross-fed across the pods.
Now, the consequence to the flight control
system, there were different constraints and
simultaneous jet firings.
And how you counted, whether it was only left
or right or both, depending on which mode
you were in, if you had a mission and needed
a lot of RCS propellant and you had spare
space in the OMS tanks, it allowed benefiting
from that.
Why are there so many thrusters pointing in
the same direction?
For redundancy?
Yes, redundancy and maximum control authority.
You want to find control authority normally
with redundancy but for external tank separation
you wanted high acceleration in one direction.
For high rendezvous breaking you wanted high
acceleration in the other direction plus or
minus Z.
And for backup to the OMS engine you wanted
to have higher acceleration in the plus X
direction.
And then, when you were doing entry, which
I'm not talking about today, you had an on-demand
RCS control authority in the upper atmosphere
during hypersonic flight.
And you would turn on one, two, three or four
yaw thrusters in particular as needed.
I think one, two, and occasionally three thrusters
had been turned on during disturbances.
One of the things we've learned from the telemetry
of the Columbia accident is as this vehicle
was falling apart for probably 20 or 30 seconds,
the vehicle was controlling very nicely because
they kept turning on more and more jets.
They were getting major torque imbalances
from missing pieces of the vehicle.
But it was still controlling the attitude
until the damage got so severe that was no
longer possible.
Again, I already talked about the number of
the thrusters.
The primary thrusters, for the reasons we
talked about, there were many jets.
And also because translation and rotation
control was accommodated by these Verniers,
a feature I will mention briefly later.
It was only a rotation control system and
fundamentally does not have redundancy.
I already talked about the on-time.
These are just typical propellant loads and
thrust levels and specific impulse numbers.
You notice that large maneuvers are always
a little more efficiently done with the primary
jets and even more efficiently still with
the OMS as you will see in another chart.
Life for duty cycles and on-time are relevant
for a vehicle that is going to fly a lot of
missions.
Flying control almost always will be done
with Vernier jets, not just because of propellant,
which it is much more efficient, but also
because you will get a lot more mission life
out of it.
This is a stick drawing of those.
There is a numbering system associated with
it.
FRL for which pot it's in.
Up, down, forward, right, left.
The last character for which direction it
fires.
And then the middle number is a manifold.
If you see a five that is the Vernier jets.
One, two, three or four, any pod that has
got the same middle number is on one manifold.
If a failure shut that manifold or a string
took down that manifold, all of those jets
were lost.
When you lose a string, you would have one
manifold per pod that you would lose.
That means under some circumstance, because
the Vernier system is redundant, a single
failure could take that out.
But that wasn't critical to carrying out most
mission objectives or to safety.
That is probably enough said on that.
The OMS, typical propellant loads mentioned
here.
On-time, never less than two seconds.
Never less than, with one engine, 12,000 pound
second impulse with a 6,000 pound thrust not
suitable for fine maneuvers.
The RCS jets would always be used to trim
out any large OMS burn errors.
Had a significantly higher specific impulse.
For large maneuvers you're clearly better
off from a propellant weight perspective using
that system.
Each of the engines had redundant gimbal control,
redundant by having one mechanical screw system,
but you could drive the nut or you could drive
the screw.
And there were different electrical systems
that did that.
This was the maximum authority.
And the two axes at each engine could move
a portion of which was used to tract the center
of mass as the vehicle consumed propellant
or delivered payloads and a portion of which
was for actual thrust vector control management.
We also had to subtract a little bit.
You never want to go too close to the hard
stops because you risk mechanical failure
by doing that.
And you always have a little bit of mechanical
uncertainty of exactly where you are anyway.
A portion of that was a mechanical uncertainty
and a portion of that was just a mechanical
safety margin.
This is a drawing in the two different planes
of the rotation of the engines showing the
span between the center, say about 15 feet
apart, no surprise given the general cross-section
of the Shuttle.
An important thing to notice is that the engine,
while I can point through the CG, is not pointing
anywhere near the body access of the vehicle.
And, by the way, the vehicle body axes weren't
-- There was a significant offset between
the principle axis of the vehicle and the
body axis component of inertia, and the body
axis was quite large.
Three units, even with the replacements they
have gone through over the years, there remains
three units for the INSs now, but the IMU
where mechanical systems with quanta for knowledge
of state which were not all that small.
And the RGAs were even worse, the rate gyros.
These quanta were quite significant.
The reason was we had a half-word in that
multiplexity multiplexer for translating the
analog signal to a digital signal which determined,
based on the maximum range, the maximum range
being dictated by maneuver rates where possible
during ascent and entry and not on orbit.
But we were stuck with that.
It was hardwired into the cards.
And so these quanta then, we discovered there
was a one sigma probability of an every third
cycle one quanta noise spike on the data that
came across the MDMs.
And that was pretty significant when we were
trying to do fine control during the transition
phase.
Were the noise levels determined by this quantization,
in effect, the [NOISE OBSCURES]?
The noise phenomenology was related to the
electronics of the card, but it was directly
related to the least significant byte.
But the mechanical sensors themselves were
superior to that?
Yes, they were.
It was the MDM card that introduced the noise.
If you had used one word from the MDMs that
would have [NOISE OBSCURES]?
Given the state-of-the-art to have processed
that much information across the MDMs would
have made it too slow.
We're talking orders of magnitude slower electronics
from the late `70s than you have today, so
the half-word was dictated by the data rates
that we required of these boxes.
Now I'm going to go into specific features
on the software side.
Yeah?
With the gyros, it seems on Hubble and Station,
for example, we always hear bad news on the
gyros having to be replaced every so often.
Well, first of all, what I'm talking about
here, at the time the Shuttle first flew,
are mechanical gyros.
Hubble may have started mechanical gyros.
They have been changed out at least once or
twice.
And are probably fiber optic systems.
Hubble has the problem that it's in a fairly
high orbit, 300 plus nautical miles high for
the Shuttle anyway.
It has a significant radiation exposure, particularly
when it goes through the South Atlantic Anomaly
of the radiation belts which are 300 nautical
miles.
Much more time they spend on that than at
100 nautical miles.
Cumulative radiation damage to the electronics
in those gyros is probably a contributing
factor to the failure rates that they're seeing
on Hubble.
I would say they must spend a few percentage
of their time in the South Atlantic Anomaly
at that altitude.
Are the gyro replacements we're talking about
measurement gyros or attitude control gyros?
Well, the fine guidance gyros are the ones
that have been the big problem on the Hubble.
We're talking about quantitatively a different
regime we're operating here.
The quantization, take away the noise effects,
was something we could live with for operating
the flight control system.
In Hubble, you want to be able to measure
rates two or three orders of magnitude lower
than what we're talking about here.
The actual design of the sensors is substantially
different because they're trying to get very,
very tiny little rates out.
These are trying to maintain the image lock
when you're using the full magnification capability
of the telescope and whatever target that
it has.
Nevertheless, I would imagine that if the
Shuttle gyros are staying at 300 nautical
miles for five to ten years, they would fail,
too.
Radiation is one of the fundamental drivers
for all missions.
And it often that Atlantic Anomaly is one
of the big drivers for low inclination.
Space telescopes are 28.5 degree inclinations.
So they don't have to deal with the magnetic
fields coming in toward the poles which a
polar mission has to, but there is this big
dip in the Van Allen Belts off the coast of
South America which poses a problem for everything
that isn't low orbit.
The functionality we have in the autopilot,
we use the rate gyros and the inertial measurement
unit on the transitioned app to get states
direction giving us altitude, giving us rate.
On orbit we have the gyro shutdown to conserve
power, view data only.
That then dictates that we are going to have
a state estimator on orbit.
We have to put some special features to overcome
the rate gyro noise in the transition phase,
which is irrelevant when the rate gyros aren't
operating in the on-orbit phase.
We have the Vernier jets and the associated
algorithm logic for on-orbit which isn't in
the transition phase.
We worry a lot more about every detail propellant
deficiency on-orbit because we spend so much
more time there.
We have a lot of features we've added to minimize
propellant there.
The OMS capability in the two phases is actually
identical with both of them having a capability
to wrap around the RCS jets to the thrust
vector control should the thrust vector control
not behave properly during that OMS burn.
And this just delineates the various features
we have for steering.
OMS and RCS.
Where we add lots more features because there
are a lot more things you are attempting to
track when you're doing your mission on orbit
than when you're just trying to get to and
from orbit.
Notice the rates that we're talking about.
Typically, you look at an INS box these days
and you see hundreds of hertz data rates.
What restricted us here was how fast could
we -- For instance, none of the software was
in the sensor package.
It was in our computer.
And we had a severe throughput problem.
And the solution, since we had the rate gyros
for rates and we only needed the IMUs for
attitudes, and rates could be used to extrapolate
attitudes for a reasonable period of time,
was to greatly reduce the processing rate
of the IMU down to on the order of one hertz,
submultiple of 25 hertz which is why it is
1.04.
On orbit, since it was our only source of
information, we had to eat a larger processing
burden, operating on a 6.25 hertz, but we
still were extrapolating in between the state
estimate of one time constant.
We'll talk a little bit about what we're doing
with that, but everything down here is operating
at 12.5 and we're getting the data in at 6.25.
There are a lot of things you would do differently
simply because you don't have these low rate
constraints due to throughput limits.
The architecture then for the autopilot that
is being representative on orbit is you would
have a maneuver module where all the features
for steering the vehicle would be, kind of
an adjunct to guidance.
You would have these modes controlled by the
crew and the push button display of what the
stick deflections would do.
You would have the phase plane which would
be tracking attitude error, rate error and
whether or not you should fire jets as a function
of those errors separate per axis.
Are there people here that don't know about
phase planes?
OK.
Well, the concept of the phase plane, you
go to optimal control theory and you look
into a situation where you have a control
effector which is on or off by directional,
which is what thrusters are.
And you look at what it takes, given an error
in a plane which is attitude error and rate
error, and you want to get minimum time to
neutralize that error to zero.
51:35 But you have
lots of dead zones, which I will talk about
more, to assure that you don't inefficiently
use the jets so that you are not constantly
trying to fire the jets to get exactly to
the origin which is never possible.
The state estimator, which is a form of a
Kalman filter.
And then the jet selection logic which is
essentially for the primary jet lookup tables.
But it turned out to probably be the first
use of real based intelligence.
We didn't think about these things in that
time.
And, when I talk about the stringing later,
I think we were also using an early version
of failure tree analysis.
But, in the 1970s, none of these things were
named.
And then you have various loads for the parameters
that determine these dead zones and tables
and all that.
And the crew would select these from push
button displays.
For the OMS, you could either have hand controller
inputs or cross-product steering and based
guidance inputs which would then go into roll
and pitch and yaw.
Thrust vector processing channels were roll
and pitch coupled.
Roll is only possible, of course, when you're
firing two engines by differentially pitching
the gimbals on the two engines.
This would actually be an RCS loop automatically
with one engine, but you had to have the two
pads coupled when you were trying to do both
of them.
But the yaw axis was separate.
Just keeping in mind the time.
Go through one or two more charts before the
break?
That's fine.
I will go through the state estimator and
then we can take a short break.
The state estimator, again, we were only getting
attitude information at 6.25 hertz from the
primary thrusters trying to maintain an estimate
of the vehicle rotation rates.
We also wanted to know what disturbances on
orbit you can have out-gassing the vehicle.
You have gravity gradients.
You have aero torques which have a diurnal
variation depending on where you are on earth
orbit relative to where the sun is which are
tending to torque the vehicle in a particular
direction.
Having knowledge of how that torque is behaving
in a certain time enables you to manipulate
your phase plane switching lines to more efficiently
use the jets.
We were trying to estimate that.
Given that we only had IMU data with noise
and quantization effects, we also had flexure
we weren't accounting for in doing that.
So we had a low rate filter which incorporated
the measurements directly and a higher rate
filter which was also taking in feed forward
information we're going to fire the jets.
We expect these velocity changes, rotational
and translational, to occur as a result of
the jet firing.
And you can build that into the estimate to
anticipate that effect.
And then, given all that information, basically
use that in the form of a common filter.
We had different gains associated with primary
and Vernier jet usage because, given the factor
of 30 difference in the rotational acceleration
authority of these jets, they were fundamentally
different bandwidth systems on the basis of
the actuators.
We accommodated those different bandwidths
in the software.
That, by the way, affected us when we started
worrying about flexure on the arm because
we found that some of the modes with heavy
payloads in the arm actually fell within this
bandwidth.
And, in the case of the Vernier jets, were
falling right near the roll off point, which
was the worst possible place to have a flexure
mode.
And there were some significant design issues
that were addressed later in the program as
a result of that.
And then this disturbance acceleration -- Question.
At the time that you were designing these,
was there sufficient knowledge of the structural
modes or the bending modes?
For the RMS payload operations, not at all.
We first learned about that when we started
looking at use of the arm to deploy the SPAS
one payload in STS-7.
Nobody understood at the time we were designing
for the first Shuttle flight the kind of coupling
effects you would get from payloads on the
arm.
It hadn't been modeled yet.
I would say probably about the time the first
flights were occurring is when we started
to look at that stuff, but the Shuttle software
for the first flight was 95% frozen by '78,
even though the flight didn't occur until
'81.
You then discovered them in simulations or
from flight data?
No, it was from high-fidelity simulations
with the arm dynamics included in that.
We understood it pretty well.
We refined it after the flights.
We did even do some flight tests on STS-8
with an object called a payload flight test
article.
The original payload on that flight couldn't
fly in time so they put this 8,000 pound dumbbell
on there and the arm was able to manipulate.
Went through all kinds of exercises and pretty
much validated it with the simulations.
Were towing us at that point in time.
But it was a real lot of work that went into
those high-fidelity robotic arm simulations
and coupling that to the flight control system
to get those numbers.
And a lot of work into evaluating what it
all meant in terms of restrictions on the
use of the control system.
And then the last thing I will talk about
before the break, the disturbance acceleration
estimator had a 56 second time constant.
Mostly the disturbances we are talking about
were either orbital or semi-orbit, half-orbit
type of periodicity.
You wanted to allow adequate time to integrate
and determine their effect, but not so long
that you weren't able to properly respond
to it.
Somewhere in the one-minute range seemed to
be about right for something that would have
45 minute periodicity.
And I think the next topic will be RCS processor.
And that is a good point to take the break.
Before we break, let me ask one historical
question.
The timeframe for the design of this was mid
to late '70s?
We began the work in '75.
There was a famous phase of '76 which is the
Hay Scrub which is where we realized that
not everything can go onto one computer.
The computer memory had to increase.
The real design architecture of what was going
to be the first flight started to gel in '76.
The original expected launch date of the Shuttle
was '78.
It kind of stayed ahead of us a certain amount
of time, but we had probably 90% or 95% of
the design done by '78.
We're going through detailed flight verification
and crew training with Jeff being one of the
crew members that was assigned to us.
And we would go out to Downey to do that in
the '78 to '80 period.
In the design, now, you refer to the state
estimator and optimal control.
By that time, had that methodology been completely
accepted as a substitute for the classical
control design?
Oh, yeah, I think so.
I think the phase plane concept first appeared,
actually, in Apollo.
And there was sort of a rudimentary application
of optimal control theory that was quite successful.
By that time I think the aircraft zoom maneuver
[NOISE OBSCURES], people were happy with that.
The Kalman filter work, an early form of that
also made it into Apollo.
I don't think we were actually pushing the
envelope that much in using these things.
We actually carried over.
But Apollo, applying any of these technologies
in the mid to late `60s, was very groundbreaking.
Any other questions before the break?
OK.
Let's take five minutes.
Am I missing anybody?
I know Larry hasn't come back.
Close enough.
OK.
Well, I'm going to go into the RCS processor
now.
We've talked a lot about the presence of the
phase plane.
We're going to go into some of the details
in the jet selection.
Important consideration of the jet selection
is we had to accommodate failures, maintaining
control authority for any type of single failure,
thruster, manifold, string, which you will
see those later.
And you also had to be able to maintain adequate
authority for safety with two of those combined
failures.
We also had to limit plume restrictions, accommodate
the tank constraints.
We talked about having couples, not having
couples, the balance propellant in tanks to
limit fuel usage when you didn't worry about
translational coupling and minor orbital perturbations
and all those other special maneuvers that
we pointed out before they required higher
authority.
You had your manual modes going in and then
you had all these steering modes which without
orbit, in addition to the ones we talked about,
discrete rate and pulse and acceleration and
all that kind of stuff, you had various landmark
tracking modes, orbital object tracking modes
which were a guidance function providing inputs
to the control loop, that all had to be managed
through a proper way of manipulating the phase
plans.
They were tracking the errors of matter with
respect to the mode that you were in and then
sending, based on the errors being detected
in the phase plane commands, they would be
processed by the jet selection logic.
The principles of the phase plane, we figured
you weren't important enough to get started.
[LAUGHTER] You had a phase plane per axis.
Roll.
Pitch.
Yaw.
You had switch lines which were shaped based
on the expected torques.
You always had a parabolic feature, but much
more complicated than just that.
You added dead bands because you didn't want
to fire.
When you didn't know exactly where you were,
you wanted to be able to get in the general
vicinity far enough from a firing zone that
it would stay in the general vicinity for
a while and then only fire when you had to
when you were diverging from that.
You had to deal in the transition phase with
that rate gyro noise phenomenology.
And you had to get the disturbance acceleration
on orbit.
What we did about all those maneuver modes
is each phase plane had an origin, the origin
being zero with respect to sun frame and attitude
and position.
You could move that origin at a rate or you
could increment its attitude position if you
were commanding the vehicle to do something
such as a tracking maneuver or a discrete
rate.
And that way the errors of the phase plane
we're looking at with respect to where you
wanted to be rather than in absolute sense.
And you would always create [NOISE OBSCURES]
in here so that if you had a big error you
could spend a little bit of fuel to get to
somewhere which would cause you to go in the
right direction without continuously firing
the jet.
Whereas, if you truly followed the parabolic
switch curve you would just keep firing the
jet until you were back to the origin which
can be quite costly.
So I am going to show you this picture and
then the on-orbit one.
These are the residual parabolic switch lines
which, in the optimal control theory, would
be going through the origin.
And then if you're out over in these region
out here you will always fire a jet meaning
a plus direction or the minus direction.
You're inside here.
You will fire until you hit another switch
line on the other side.
The expectation is that you're coming in this
way or you're coming in this way.
You want to get to a point where you're not
likely to fire again for a while.
But then you also would be concerned because
you don't automatically want to fire back
right away because the rate gyro noise phenomenology
could cause, where you think you are with
respect to that line, to move back and forth
causing you to fire too soon, causing the
fire again to reverse that and get in trouble.
So what we actually did is if you actually
hit this line and began to fire, each time
you fired up to two or three times it would
move the line out temporarily so that the
quantum noise from that MDM would not make
you think, even though you were moving this
way, that you were going back out.
Because, if you fired that jet again, not
only would you be spinning the propellant
to go faster, you'd hit the other line a lot
faster still.
For every time you double the size of the
impulse that you use to reverse your rate,
you're quadrupling the total propellant time.
Because, if you double the propellant each
time, you hit a surface twice as fast before
you get to the next one.
Now, on-orbit we didn't have that noise problem
so we don't have that moving switch line there.
But we have this moving switch line.
If you're coming in you're looking to hit
the zero line and cut off, but here you're
not going to cut off until you hit the disturbance
acceleration line.
It is expecting, when you hit that, that the
predicted acceleration is going to say you're
going to go up this way.
That means it will be longer before you hit
another surface than if you start doing that
over here.
So this one is a trick to lower the frequency
of the jet firings based on other knowledge
that we had about the acceleration.
Jet selection.
We had entirely different laws for the primary
and the Vernier.
The Verniers had a very complicated configuration,
had to be able to be fault tolerant, be able
to handle simultaneous translation rotation
commands.
It turned out, because of throughput processing
limits, the correct approach was something
like a table lookup.
But we had all kinds of rules we went through
to say which kind of table did we want to
go to?
What are the consequences of failures?
Do we want to start modifying the commands
we've received because of what we basically
know about which jets have failed and what
we no longer can accomplish?
We actually had a Bullion implementation of
those tables that actually got implemented
as tables because we developed algorithms
and IBM converted the software.
And they didn't necessarily do exactly what
we told them.
Subsequent to that there was an experiment
on the Shuttle called a phase space autopilot
which is based on looking for velocity changes
and optimal combinations of jets.
You would go through a linear optimal search
and find the combinations.
That was flown a couple times for a few hours
on Shuttle.
The experiment was quite successful but never
converted into a basic shuttle capability.
But certainly with the processing capability
that you have now would be a very good option
as an alternative to what we did.
The Vernier jets, which were only used on
orbit, only had six jets.
We weren't trying to deal with redundancies
so an entirely different kind of scheme was
done there.
We were looking to find the jets with respect
to a three-axis command which best contributed
to producing rates in that direction.
We could find a first jet that would be the
best jet.
And then we could see, given how good that
one is, is there another one which is half
as good?
If so, we would pick it.
And, if we found one half as good, we might
say if there is another one which is half
again as good we might pick that and end up
with an aggregate number of jets we would
turn on to start producing the command.
This would be based not just on whether or
not the phase plane said you should have a
jet fire in an axis, but also on how big the
error was but not yet to the point of hitting
the phase plane line in the other axis.
And so the composite vector you were trying
to neutralize would be a combination of the
command and error reduction on the other axes.
And you would find the jets which would then
respond your command and reduce the errors
on the other axes.
Now, we would not re-compute that every cycle.
If we found that the ones or minus ones in
the three axes for the commands were not changing,
even though the fractional values and the
uncommand of axes were changing for up to
five cycles we would not re-compute the jets.
And that would minimize the duty cycles which
was a life issue on the jets.
And then there was the other phenomenology
I mentioned which is you start having large
payloads or you're attached to Mir or something
like that.
Mass properties are very different.
We don't know about that unless the crew tells
us, but we could put a discrete number of
alternative configurations in the tables for
what we expected accelerations of the jets
would be.
The crew could tell us which one applies,
and then it would do this selection based
on that.
The Vernier algorithm looks something like
this flow chart.
Whereas, the primary algorithm would probably
fill a 50 page flowchart.
The Vernier algorithm was very simple.
You go through and have a command vector which
was ones and minus ones or fractional values,
depending on whether or not phase planes have
commanded an axis or just had a bias because
of an error in that axis.
You would do a dot product of the six jets.
You would look for the maximum value of that
dot product of the acceleration and the command.
And then, based on that value of that dot
product, you would see if there was one that
was half as good.
And, if there was one as half as good, you
would see if there was one that was a quarter
as good.
And then, if we already selected, we would
be doing this counter of up to five times
where we wouldn't recomputed.
Now, I was just talking during the break about
one of the constraints on here.
When we were using these computers, the dot
product of a three vector by three vector
took about one millisecond.
We had an 80 millisecond cycle.
And, in that 80 millisecond cycle, seven to
ten milliseconds could be allocated to control
some of the guidance and some of the other
functions.
Six milliseconds was being used to do these
dot products.
That is why we never could have considered
doing something like that for the primary
jets.
The TVC processor, we have instead of discrete
control with thrusters, we have nearly continuous
control because we're doing gimbal steering
up to the nonlinear effect of a gimbal limit.
Remind them what TVC is.
Thrust vector control.
Moving the thrust of the OMS engine by steering
the gimbals on which it is attached, which
you cannot do with the RCS thrusters.
What we would do then is cross-product steering.
You have an error vector and a thrust vector,
and the cross-product between the two could
tell you the direction you needed to steer
the vehicle to turn into the desired direction
you wanted to thrust.
That steering command was then used to determine
the commands we sent to the gimbals for moving
the engines.
You had manual and automatic modes for doing
that.
Generally, we were limited to two degrees
per second because the gimbals were fairly
slow.
We didn't want to get ourselves in a situation
where we over-steered and had to correct back
which would take a lot of time and maybe cost
us some propellant.
But, if we got into trouble, the reaction
control system could wrap around.
And that could happen automatically if the
errors got big enough or the crew could induce
that by hitting the hand controller.
And you have the two pads going into the manual
auto mode.
And manual always overrides auto from any
of these operations.
We had a lot of things we had to tolerate
in determining our filter gains.
We didn't always know the thrust direction
engines all that way because of mechanical
misalignment.
When you build this thing an additional misalignment
occurs after you launch the thing causing
changes in the gimbal drive connections a
little bit.
There are errors.
You rotate to a desired burn direction with
the RCS jets before you light the engines.
You're never exactly there when you start
up.
You can have failures during burns.
An engine can shut down.
An actuator can stop driving.
If it is the OMS-1 burn in the early Shuttle
days, during that burn they were dumping the
residual oxygen and hydrogen in the feed lines
for the main engines during the burn causing
torque disturbance on the vehicle that we
had to overcome.
The OMS burn actually helped drive that fluid
out of those lines.
And then, of course, we had steering noise
and bias.
And then we had to have margins for things
that all liquid propellant vehicles have.
Slosh, flexure, actuator nonlinearities and
sample rate effects.
Now we had a design and then we had to change
it.
And the reason we had to change it is we flew
for a little while, and we discovered that
these brushless electric motors being used
for the OMS actuators were turning on and
off at a high enough rate during the burns
that they were overheating making a hundred
mission life maybe two or three missions.
And they could take the pods off, but they
were fairly hard to get and expensive to maintain.
So they asked us to change the bandwidth.
And that's what we did beginning with the
twelfth shuttle flight making these changes
here.
And that caused a little bit more sloppy behavior
at the beginning and the end of the burn but
didn't make very appreciable difference on
the performance and made a big difference
on the actuator life.
There was an outer loop just showing where
the cross-product steering comes in and the
fact that there are various filters and digital
compensation effects that are going into this
to deal in an adequate manner with all those
effects that I listed a few minutes ago.
The wraparound was there because we have the
means to cover for large perturbations.
Why not implement it?
I mean the situation you always have with
human space flight, if there was a capability
you can take advantage of in a contingency
scenario put it in.
This also changed, though, between the first
flight and the twelfth flight.
And the reason we found is that you put this
contingency capability in, but when you really
study it you realize you can actually take
these two fundamentally different control
laws and cause them to interact adversely.
We could perturb it and then induce the jets
to fire in a way that would cause it to counteract
the effect that the thrust vector control
system was doing.
So, when we lowered the bandwidth, we also
changed some of the parameters in there to,
in combination, preclude that first flight.
This is a case where we continued to evaluate
the baseline system after we were flying and
discovered additional potential unanticipated
deficiencies that we should fix, which is
saying you're never done analyzing the system
even after it starts flying.
The maneuver and track modes, I mentioned
that they were there, but we had this universal
pointing display that the crew could manipulate.
Yes?
On that last general comment, on the last
subject of discovering issues and potential
problems after the system is flying.
You're doing the analysis.
You're doing your research.
What, in general, were the reactions of your
NASA counterparts when you bring that to their
attention?
Would they call for an immediate fix before
the next launch?
It depended on the nature of the problem.
And let me mention two or three of them at
one time.
I mentioned one about that phenomenology for
the excitation or the rocking motion on the
tank.
And then another one with the Vernier jets
which I will explain in a moment.
The external tank one had to be fixed before
a second shuttle flight.
There was one that potentially created a dangerous
situation.
Tank separation violated safety of flight
rules.
This one was a potential wraparound interaction.
It could only occur if you already had a significant
contingency under fairly complex conditions.
And, if the crew knew about it, there was
a procedural way to temporarily inhibit the
reaction control system interactions stopping
the effect.
Because there was a crew workaround, they
knew about the problem, it was deemed acceptable
to go some number of missions for an already
scheduled software update to insert it.
Now, the third problem discovered as a result
of analysis of STS-1 and 3 was a plume and
pendulum phenomenology of the down firing
aft jets.
The body flap sticks out as kind of a random
position on orbit, and the down firing thrusters,
part of their plume hits it.
They had evaluated that effect for the primary
jets because they knew in the direction they
pointed and their lower expansion ratio in
the Vernier jets there was going to be a problem.
And that was properly dealt with in the flight
control system.
They never modeled for the Vernier jets, but
only discovered that the state estimator was
not converging as well as expected on the
first Shuttle flight when using the Vernier
jets.
And it turned out there was probably a 20%
or 30% net reduction in thrust and a 15 or
20 degree effective change in the direction
of the thrusts, those two down firing Verniers.
And the feed forward estimation from the RCS
jets, as a result, was giving the wrong data
in the state estimator causing a jump in the
value and a long time constant to settle out.
And that was causing a few percent increase
in the propellant consumption but probably
a factor of ten increase in the duty cycles
of the jets which was unacceptable from the
life of the jets.
That was compounded by a problem in STS-3
which is the first time they used the arm.
And they actually put a few hundred pound
payload and tried controlling the attitude
of the vehicle in moving that payload.
The combination of those things they went
back and, by STS-5, had to make serious changes
to the phase plane estimation logic and tables
for the accelerations for those Vernier jets
because they didn't want to burn those jets.
I think, after STS-2, they actually changed
some of the jets.
And then they didn't want to have to change
them again.
The maneuver mode.
You want to do various types of [NOISE OBSCURES]
maneuvers with respect to various frames of
reference which could be landmark tracking,
local vertical tracking, second spacecraft
if you're doing a rendezvous tracking.
Guidance to provide that.
That would be broken down into components
by axis.
And then there was an additional level of
hysteresis about what you were telling the
face plane to do.
And I talked about adjusting the origin.
This would decide whether or not you would
adjust the origin.
If you're error in a given axis with respect
to what you wanted to do with the maneuver
was less than twice the dead band, you would
not adjust the origin.
And if it was more than twice you would.
And, again, it is a case of why force it to
do things it doesn't have to do if it's going
to get there eventually anyway?
And that is actually an adjustable parameter
which, for certain payload missions, they
might change that value from something else.
There were these various direct manual translation
rotation modes and the auto modes that I think
bit by bit I have talked about.
The reason you have these different references,
inertial and local vertical, if you're doing
an earth observation mission, almost everything
is going to be in a local vertical frame.
You're going to have your payload bay pointing
down.
You want to keep it pointed at a certain spot.
If you're doing a solar telescope mission,
everything is going to be in an inertial frame.
You're going to want to keep it pointing at
the sun or within a few degrees where maybe
the telescope will have a limited travel of
its own.
If you're doing rendezvous then it's going
to have to be you're accounting for the orb
rates of the two vehicles.
You're going to want to keep your rendezvous
radar pointed in the right direction.
By the way, the rendezvous radar, there is
a deployable dish antenna that goes out of
the payload bay, the side of the payload bay
of the Shuttle.
That is a dual-purpose antenna.
It can be used to point at the TDRS satellite
to send data at high rates to the earth and
track the satellite.
Or it can be used to point a radar beam at
another spacecraft.
It was not used for TDRS in the beginning
of the program.
It was only used for radar because the first
TDRS was launched by STS-6.
Electronic string, and I think we're about
at the right point of time on this, too, to
allowing me to get into this in a little bit
of detail.
This was something that kind of crept up on
us in importance.
It was thought it would make the systems redundant,
have separate strings, don't put them all
on the same computer.
All those things were recognized, but I don't
think until about a year, a year and half
before the first flight actually occurred
that we realized how difficult it is to be
sure that all the interactions of these strings,
the power string, the pluming string and the
electronic string and the possible combinations
of failures, how difficult it is to assure
that you meet those high level failure tolerance
requirements.
And that is what I think I did in 1980, '81,
probably was the early form of fault tree
analysis.
And I have in a handbook I developed for the
first flight, a series what if tables with
all these different breakdowns of what could
happen.
And actually a person that didn't know about
probabilities and all looked at it.
It was a pretty scary table when you looked
at all the possible bizarre two failure combinations.
But first you've got to understand what the
strings are.
You would have one forward, one aft left,
one aft right, so three boxes, three half
boxes and multiplexers-demultiplexers on a
string.
And there were two MDM boxes in each pod,
forward left right aft.
And the electronics were broken apart into
each half box.
So you actually had, in effect, four sets
of electronics in each pod, even though you
only had two boxes.
And one card from each of those boxes would
be dedicated to string, but each string would
have a card per pod.
So three cards would be tied electronically
to one computer anomaly.
Now, you couldn't take a string that could
be commanded by more than one computer.
The computer saw the data from all four strings
so they could vote the data to decide whether
or not each of the computers was healthy,
but they could only command one string.
I should say each string could only be commanded
by one computer, but you could, if you started
losing computers, latch up more than one string
to one computer.
Even though one string could only take commands
from one computer, more than one string could
take commands from the same computer if that
became necessary.
If you lost a computer and were in a benign
environment and you wanted to recover all
those systems, that happened with the first
computer failure in STS-9, then you would
manually re-latch those strings to a healthy
computer.
Of course, if that computer went down then
it would take two strings down.
There was a unique latch up of these string
components to power systems, but it wasn't
necessarily one-to-one.
And that is where things got very complicated,
when you start crossing the subsystems where
one power system could cause some subsystems
to fail on more than one string.
Then you take a string down.
That would be a very different failure scenario
than taking two strings down.
This is showing how the thrusters laid out.
You can see there are a lot of thrusters on
each string.
If you go back and look at the vehicle carefully
and you look at the down firing thrusters,
you will see that in the front of the tank
there are two thrusters that point down to
the left and two thrusters that point down
to the right candid out about 40 degrees.
That means that if you lose two thrusters,
two strings or two manifolds it was possible
to lose both of them on one side.
That is very important because that's one
of the phenomena we had to protect against
for separating from the external tank.
And it becomes a highly coupled separation
maneuver.
And there were some special jet select tables
created for that and some special control
logic loops that were created just for that
one scenario.
You go through these things and certain critical
events where things cannot fail even if your
subsystems have failed twice.
And the subsystems may not have been designed
to make it very convenient, but you still
have to do it.
That happens to be one of the scenarios we
looked at a lot.
And that we see forward down left down left
or forward down right down right.
So somehow you lose the thrusters, these strings
or whatever.
That became a special design case.
And there were a lot of those kinds of things.
I would say 70% or 80% of our design time
goes into learning those special cases.
With the thrusters the manifolds are basically
the valve lines, so there is a commonality
between the electronic stringing of manifolds
in those valves.
With the OMS that's not really true.
The way the OMS engines work, each engine
[NOISE OBSCURES] is actually an oxidizer and
fuel tank going into two loops of lines each
with two valves.
At least one valve in each path had to open
to feed fuel.
At least both valves in one loop had to close
to stop fuel from flowing.
Any combination which would leave two open
after a burn started or would leave two closed
before the burn started was a problem.
Then you have pressure sensors.
And there was only one per engine.
You lacked insight into whether or not the
engine started based on pressure if one of
those failed.
The stringing of this was not the same as
the electronic string, so we had to start
looking at the possibility of individual valve
failures and electronic string failures.
Taking down other valves.
Did that happen before an engine started,
after an engine started?
How did that correlate with then influence
on the same engine's actuator control?
We could get situations where we could start
the engine but we couldn't steer it, engines
that we could steer but couldn't start it,
and so we ended up with this maze of tables
looking at those situations coming up with
contingency designs.
Sometimes reverting to using the XRCS jets
under severe multiple failure scenarios that
actually do deorbit burns.
We talked about what could go down.
All of these things could be lost with a single
failure, though not all strings have an IMU
because there are only three.
And only two of the chamber pressure.
Some strings were more important than others
with respect to a subset of the systems.
And since there are only two thrusters on
one manifold per pod of the Verniers, there
are also only three strings that affected
those.
All this got set up so that any one failure
was quite manageable, but the moment you talked
about any possible two failures was when it
became much more complicated.
Generally, where we ended up, after lots and
lots of special design accommodation was we
tolerated loss of translation control in the
axes that were not necessary for managing
deorbit.
We tolerated degradation and rotation control
but assured that we retained it, at least
in a time average sense, in all three axes.
The biggest complexity here was assuring we
still had adequate time averaged translation
and rotation control for tank separation.
So we would pull away without recontacting
the tank.
Remember, recontacting the tank meant tiles
hitting the tank.
Those tiles are really fragile.
They can survive thousands of degrees but
not much impact.
We accommodated the scenario where we could
lose all thrust vector control on the OMS
engines and still do a deorbit burn usually
with RCS wraparound properly designed.
And we had to accommodate the situations where
MDMs did not reset, so everything tied to
an MDM would be lost.
And that is the kind of situation where you
start having valve here, a valve here, a valve
there being shut down along with a bunch of
jets.
And the real pain was understanding what things
could collectively go down together.
You had to lay out all the faults, all the
things that could happen with each of the
faults and then overlaying the combinations
of those.
And then you would find it wasn't everything
you were worried about.
It was usually a small fraction, but those
few fractions drove the design details and
effort to a great degree.
Now, on orbit, because you would often being
using one IMU and you only had two computers,
one of those strings going down meant you
lost your navigation base.
But because you're in a relatively benign
environment, restringing and bringing up another
system wasn't a problem.
If you were doing terminal rendezvous with
the Space Station, you would not be in a one
IMU mode.
You would be in a three IMU mode on two computers,
but you would not lose your navigation base.
If you lost a computer at a critical point
in that, you would probably abort the rendezvous,
reconfigure again and resume your operations.
One of the ground rules for all rendezvous
operations with the Shuttle, and I think will
be true of the CVE is an rendezvous operation
planned to do has to be able to be repeated
at least once.
The way I want to end this, and then we could
have questions, is two pictures, before and
after cockpit upgrade on the Shuttle.
This was the way the Shuttle was for many
flights.
Those are CRT displays, green monochrome where
no images could be drawn except little sticks,
dots and lines and rudimentary.
These are analog tape measures, analog eight
ball with analog needles for attitude and
rate information.
And really very 1970s.
Comment on that.
One of the things that we did as payload specialists
is we got some training in the cockpit, and
that was the version that was available in
the early `90s when I was down there.
And you would go from your desk at the Johnson
Space Center when you were using an IMB Think
Pad or something, and you felt as though you
had gone through a time warp when you went
back to the simulator on what was the world's
most expensive vehicle.
It was extraordinary.
And, of course, you could explain why this
was kept on so long.
Well, it was this multi seven digit figure
for its upgrade, as well as the issue about
recertification.
And let me mention both of those in a moment,
point out a couple of things and get back
to that before I show you the current configuration.
[AUDIENCE QUESTION] The amount in the Shuttle
versus the amount to support the Shuttle?
In the Shuttle because [NOISE OBSCURES].
Well, you only have a 104k memory computer.
You have the actual number of lines that are
[NOISE OBSCURES].
Yeah, you had the 104k for the backup system,
the 104k for ascent and entry, the 104k for
on-orbit, the 104k for system management.
And then there have been other things where
their own software capabilities have been
added in subsequent years.
So it is a lot of software now, but human
validation means if you make small change
everything has to be reassessed for possible
interaction to a degree that you would never
do for a mission that doesn't put human safety
at risk.
That means the cost of doing that each time
is probably an order of magnitude higher than
it would be for an unmanned system.
You look at what it was going to take to put
a cockpit upgrade in there.
We're talking hundreds of millions of dollars
to do it for the fleet.
And when I say hundreds of millions, a couple
hundred million.
It did eventually get done, as I will show
you in the next picture, but the main reason
was obsolescence rather than wanting to be
contemporary.
You cannot buy these pieces to replace them
anymore.
The companies that actually made some of these
systems may not exist.
Or, if they do, they have no economic incentive
for maintaining the base for a customer that
may buy another five of them.
And so, one of the things you have to deal
with when a system is going to do this many
years, another example of that is the B-52
or the Triton missiles or things that stay
in operation for a long time, is you have
to plan, as part of your operation cost, for
periodic upgrades to mitigate obsolescence.
[AUDIENCE QUESTION] In some program they had
some support.
It was Digital microcomputers.
We had a room over in the Hill building that
had about 100 of them stacked up as backups.
I don't think the boxes ever got opened.
I think the program did the buy, but the program
never lasted as long as it was supposed to.
But you are right.
You can try to buy it.
But, even so, even unused systems had a shelf
life.
And you don't know how good they are going
to be 30 years later.
If you had asked me in 1978 how long the Shuttle
was going to fly before it was replaced, I
would have said ten years, maybe 15.
Before the Columbia accident they were talking
about another 20.
It is only the safety issues now that are
going to make them stop it soon.
Anyway, the other thing I want to point out
here, this is the crew interaction mechanism,
a push button display.
No such thing as GUI.
That is unheard of in the Shuttle.
Can you talk a bit about the hand controllers?
Are they the same ones used for landings that
are also used for docking?
I mean was it the same hand controller for
everything?
It is the same hand controller for everything,
except there is another station in the back,
I didn't bring a picture of it, which is used
for docking.
The cockpit, you're looking out the forward
windows, you turn around and there is another
set of cockpit instrumentation, hand controllers.
And there are two windows above you and two
windows looking on the payload bay.
And there are also controllers there for the
arm.
Everything related to the arm is done looking
out toward the payload bay.
The arm is attached there.
When you are doing rendezvous you're looking
out at the overhead windows of the vehicle
you are approaching.
So, in effect, you have a couple of these
CRT displays and identical hand controller
and the equivalent then or the updated equivalent
now of these displays on a back station.
To avoid any issues of changing controllers
and changing viewpoints, you might note that
normally the controls that are done out of
the back window with that separate controller
and separate displays are done by different
crew members.
That is typically a mission specialist's job,
not a pilot or commander job, and so they
are separately trained.
Right.
That's an important point.
For rendezvous and docking, it is the pilot
or commander who uses the aft controls to
control [NOISE OBSCURES].
Do you know?
I believe that everything related to the RMS
that you said is correct.
But for a rendezvous the commander is always
involved.
But the point was that in that case that is
done out the rear window.
It is still done at the rear window, so he
has got to mentally reverse his frame of reference
while he is doing that.
That is correct.
[NOISE OBSCURES] And that is something that
I think will not be done with the CEV.
The same frame of reference will be used on
the CEV because I think that has always been
a little bit of a point of contention in the
problems of maintaining simultaneous proficiency.
For remote manipulation with the arm that
has been an issue.
Yeah.
And I think that has always been done by uniquely
trained mission specialists.
That's right.
Today's cockpit looks a lot more like what
you will see on a commercial airliner vintage
mid `80s, the late `80s perhaps, but still
more familiar where you've got glass multicolored
displays.
The eight ball still exists in image form
because that is what a lot of the astronauts
used to learn how to fly these vehicles.
They still fly with respect to it, except
it is a digital representation, but you're
still not with the gooey environment.
You still won't have touch pads or a mouse.
It is all pushbutton displays.
And there is a case to be made that touch
displays or touch screens don't work very
well in a vehicle where you G environments
keep changing.
It is very difficult to get a touch display
that works with a light touch and a heavy
touch when you're in zero G or when you're
pulling several Gs.
Even if the technology was space qualified,
it is not clear that they would use it, except
on a vehicle that stays in a constant environment.
At this point, let me introduce Dr. Hayashi.
Miwa Hayashi is, in fact, at NASA Ames Research
Center now, was here at MIT and worked on
the design of the next generation of the Shuttle
cockpit upgrade.
In fact, that is what you will be talking
about in ten minutes across the hall in the
16.400 class.
It is essentially what would have been done
if Shuttle life had been extended.
I might add that, although the room is very
crowded, if a few of you would like to sort
of hear where this story would have gone,
you're welcome to come across the hall to
419 and hear Dr. Hayashi.
And you are also giving a lab meeting lecture
at 1:00.
Could you tell us that subject?
That is about the astronaut scanning behavior.
Our team had a model about the astronaut's
scanning behavior in the cockpit, this upgraded
cockpit.
Anyone interested in this kind of topic you
are welcome.
It is from 1:00 PM 33206.
Thank you.
Go ahead, Phil.
Well, at this point, I think I'm open to a
few more questions.
We have a couple of minutes for further questions,
any topic we've covered or that's related
that we didn't cover.
Yeah?
You talked a lot about the constraints of
the invented computers.
[AUDIENCE QUESTION] Well, we had very large
facilities for that purpose that evolved over
time.
The first major facility was the Flight Simulation
Laboratory in Downing, California, which was
then Rockwell.
You had a room with a couple cockpits, you
had another room which had the digital interfaces
of the cockpit, and a half a floor with the
analog computers that provided a lot of the
information generation at a rate that was
not achievable with digital systems.
You had this hybrid system for driving what
were man-in-the-loop simulations.
And we spent 24 hours a day, 7 days a week
using those labs for several years.
I would often go out to California and be
on the 5:00 PM to 5:00 AM shift often spanning
weekends.
By the way, I was doing that, I think, when
I was still a graduate student, which was
kind of an interesting experience.
But then NASA built the Shuttle Avionics Integration
Laboratory in Houston which eventually superseded
the laboratory at Rockwell.
That became an all-digital system.
The hybrid systems went away.
The high capacity computers, they could fit
in one good size room everything they needed,
and were able to get much more digital displays
for the crews.
Sometimes what they used to do for the imagery
of the crew in the early days is they would
actually drive a camera across a simulated
scene because you couldn't generate the scene.
By the time they got the sail facility developed
they were able to do scene generation with
fairly high computers.
Now everything could almost be tabletop.
I mean it is just so dramatic as how this
evolved over the years.
The one thing they had at Rockwell that never
got replaced, though, is they also were able
to put into the loop actual hydraulic systems.
When they were doing entry they could turn
on aero surfaces and hydraulics with simulated
loads.
And you always knew when they were doing it
because the high pitch scream of the APUs,
when they were doing it, you could hear two
blocks away.
OK.
Last question.
Sir, I was wondering if you could give kind
of a concept of the cost of developing the
software either in man hours or in comparison
of what they spent on the hardware.
Well, the initial development of the system
probably involved the equivalent of 15 or
20 full time people for a few years.
And this was to develop the algorithms and
support the validation.
The actual flight software was actually produced
by IBM separately.
And they had a small team of people that would
take the detail design specifications and
create
the software.
It is a big effort but a very small part of
the cost of developing a Shuttle.
I mean you measure the Shuttle in billions.
You measure the flight software development
in millions.
One thing that I remember when the software
was developed and we were working and validating
it, IBM wanted every line of code change in
million dollars.
A million dollars for one line of code change
because they had to verify the whole software.
That is why you would never, unless there
was a flight critical thing, do that.
NASA wanted generally, whenever possible,
to aggregate changes for a year or maybe two
years sometimes.
And then put them in there just for that reason
because there was this huge cost of revalidating.
And that was the IBM cost.
It would be a cost to bringing us back in
to certify that, too.
Well, it worked and you should be very proud
of it, you and your colleagues.
Thank you very much, Phil.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]